haiti is still reeling from saturday's
earthquake every day more bodies are
found and the death toll continues to
rise
but even as the country mourns those
already lost another potentially ruinous
problem has arrived
tropical storm grace with the risk of
flash floods landslides and yet more
obstacles hampering the search for
survivors
it's a fresh challenge for the
government and aid organizations already
struggling to get help to a disaster
area down the road gangs are battling
over
the un has allocated eight million
dollars to help
our humanitarian colleagues are telling
us that access to the southern peninsula
where the quake hit is challenging
because gangs are controlling movements
haiti's prime minister did make it to
the seafront town of lakay one of the
worst affected cities
when i arrived in the south of the
country we saw the destruction many
houses are destroyed rescue teams are
working to find victims and survivors in
the rubble one thing i noticed was the
dignity of the people despite the
situation they are affected but
resilient they fight to survive
but even before the storm the scenes
were desperate football fields sprawled
with survivors forced to shelter with
the few belongings they have left
since the earthquake i didn't feel well
we're on the football field our home is
destroyed we can't drink the water and
many people are staying here
crisis on top of crisis last month the
country's president was assassinated
gang violence continues and in the midst
of the covert 19 pandemic haiti's only
just begun its vaccination campaign
many here also still traumatized by
events further back the 2010 earthquake
that killed hundreds of thousands of
people in port-au-prince
and in the capital many people have been
sleeping out in the streets worried
about the after shots from this
earthquake well they're not going to be
able to do that now the storm is here
haiti is suffering and the bad news
keeps on coming john holman al jazeera
porto prince